Bermuda three days ago I'm getting a
massage and this lady I said so where
are you from she says uh I'm from
Hungary so are you from Hungary yeah I
said okay what do you think about this
guy George Soros he's he's from your
country no and she stops she gets angry
what the sweetest lady he is evil do you
know how bad of a man he is he is evil
tell me you don't like him so I'm like
well I don't know much about now I'm
just kind of playing along I'm trying to
find out yeah why is he evil what did he
do to you do you know what he did when
he was 14 years old he was helping the
Nazis and he said it was okay now she's
feeding me all this stuff right but what
is the outcome is the outcome just to
destroy America and if yes who wins
because some of the people that are
destroying America are not from the
outside they're destroying from the
inside and they're living here